It's actually a wide open discussion whether randomization is actually helpful
because with  considerable analysis many randomized algorithms
can actually be turned into deterministic algorithms by using a process
called derandomization, and derandomization usually keeps fundamental properties
such as polynomial running time, all the base of the exponent.
Randomized algorithms therefore might be a bit faster
but it's unclear whether this is due to luck if you will or lack of thinking.
So, if you were to pit these two against each other, randomization versus determinism,
it's not really clear who would win or if it's a draw.
So to conclude our exploration of randomization, what might be some reasons that randomization
is actually at least a bit more powerful than determinism?
Is it that randomized algorithms are in some way harder to trick
into a worst case behavior as compared to determinism
and after all we're analyzing all of the algorithms using worst case analysis.
Is it that randomized algorithm can usually be easier to analyze than deterministic algorithms
or is it that randomized algorithms actually explore solutions
that their deterministic counterparts could miss.